[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
Papa said I gotta go to rehab I said no
no no it's Wednesday [ __ ] uncle
Joey here July 7 swingin victim and
giving out bubblegum we don't stand on
line for nobody you know I'm saying
quick bow just let you guys know the
[ __ ] going on today maybe you woke up
a little [ __ ] confused and you don't
know it's Wednesday mother [ __ ]
you're swingin dick and giving out
chlamydia like a [ __ ]
it don't matter everybody still a little
ho-hum from the firecrackers and get
your [ __ ] together that was just one day
it's Wednesday today is real [ __ ]
if you need a little pep in your step do
what I do a little almond milk smoothie
some blueberries a half a banana hello
watch the club's some [ __ ] rats back
boom Here I am that I attack with a
little bit of this [ __ ] lemon oh
Jesus left I gotta make it back to the
weave store so you know I'll be doing a
parent spoke this afternoon with the new
goodies on get toaster new fresh batches
started that the Covenant come on guys
you think I would bother you if I didn't
have good news
the [ __ ] one-eyed you is back to
[ __ ] Syria with some hash he says
gotta [ __ ] kill me some Hillary
Clinton hash you put together with a
little [ __ ] Benghazi and whatever
listen it's all over but the shouting
concert
let's so you need to know you want
chitterchat I got no jet in China this
is all you need to know we'll put our
heads together I was smoking a bowl
we'll proceed with our [ __ ] day what
else you want what do you want what do
you what do you expect from life there's
some easily knocked on your door with
the winning lottery ticket it's never
gonna happen
starts right here a little planning some
goals you know get your dick sucked and
now you're out there with a [ __ ] good
no attitude who's gonna stop me nobody
why do you think I do my meetings in the
afternoon a little jujitsu first when I
come out of it I'm sucking Kirill in the
gauge I'm little three-year-old wrong
with the [ __ ] cable debt you know
that's how I roll gradually I got some I
got a book read the book I don't know
always on [ __ ] point
that's it that's all I got feel
I came I saw I can't didn't now I walk
my daughter my regression - don't people
to see but I'm happy that together with
you know who Joey loves you brother I
love you I'm talking about I'm so
[ __ ] I see you got to suck us this
afternoon I'm gonna go weed store my
1005
put the [ __ ] buds in the front seat
let the Sun bounce down on that
[ __ ] my four o'clock comes this
shit'll be brittle I'll be are they with
you can't stop this time they bear
anything are you not so what have a good
day keep the eyes on phenomena buddy
[ __ ] with you and most important to keep
going don't [ __ ] give up I don't give
a [ __ ] what they do if this is even if
you give up they can't [ __ ] like
how's that seem so go out there tonight
grab one [ __ ] nut sack and tell them
all but Jung Eun's is being served [ __ ]
- Joey lotion